[Music]
when my life is over and I reach the
other side
I'll meet my friends from Normandy and
shake their hands with pride
[Music]
on that first landing we haven't seen
any enemy will keep later on that night
that particular point we were landing in
a foreign country and everything was
with new and exciting it was a different
world then edge of the world that
required young minima like myself to to
be prepared to die for a civilization
that was worth living
[Music]
I turn around to see the vehicle
following me another half of track with
a good friend in the same position as I
was standing up there and suddenly
clutched his throat maybe shot in the
throat killed instantly
I must abide in memory of that day he
sees our boys we've been talking to the
minutes before they were cut down with
machine-gun fire they fall into the
water floating facedown we couldn't help
them
indeed a itself the weather was so bad
in the sea conditions and I thought
about the troops city in the landing
craft I mean they awful situation for
them
amines all right for me because I was
used to the sea
you
[Music]
we're here we survived and we're here to
tell our story and there's Lance that
came with us still 18 and 19 and 20th
that line in the ground over there
sometimes I wonder who picks the ones to
die and who picks the ones to survive
[Music]